into this notion of try your best it's  not about hiring it's about firing  that's the key it's not about who you  let in it's how you get them out if  they're not right that's the skill that  we should all be focusing on because  you're gonna miss too many in the up  front and so you know that's how I do it  I you know I'm an optimist I'm a half  glass full guy like nobody wants to be  interviewing at vaynermedia because  people walk in they have no skills are  like I feel it  this kid's got it rigged it's like like  Wall Street to to who's gonna be a ninja  like I'm bad I do everyone I think  everybody can do it so they kind of try  to take me out of the equation of hiring  a Boehner but then I always clown them  like but I hired you [ __ ]